I'm going to stop on my journey biome my
quarter which was the LA second quadrant
again so I'm going to draw a triangle up
here now I do a bit of accessible that
[ __ ] right because I said to you
frequently you will get nice numbers
like this frequently but you don't
always so when it tells you Claude X is
minus 3 over 4
where is X by the way the angle X where
would you describe it I would probably
say you could add to describe it as the
angle is accountable at the origin or
just the bottom line
ok come on chump next in there so is
that where X is where are the minus 3
and the 4 or the three and the minus 4
depending on which one is I don't know
yet where are they you know okay Main
Street is this guy and heading to the
left like negative and 4 is okay so what
is the hypotenuse which means up also
yes you are going to get some search
here this is 4 squared is 16 negative 3
squared is 9 so where's this guy over
here
rude ok if you do get your wires cross
the comment in credenza there's route 5
or or jump 5 even though that would make
triangle this do the extra liner where
to just be yourself over here
just say like if that be a name for each
behind or whatever and literally write
this down just so you get that number
right because easy to do in your hand
and you've got low standards like a non
pie pick or you try it to get that wrong
ok that was all a setup
really now I think work out what 10 and
qu6 are 10 let's go with that one which
pair of on these slides are going to
give you the ratio opposite on bases so
opposite on adjacent you can see I've
just done an extra step by 3
negative of where it belongs in
simplified fraction from at the top even
though it actually come from the
denominator correct what's that yeah we
couldn't want to sign instead of
opposite our money it's important each
on opposite sound feeds Camaro market
we're up so you can see that because
sign is going to be positive here look
see if we're positive right it's going
to be instead of this on this you read
this on this funny thing yeah happy with
that you can if you want Russian like
that you can say for route 707 but
that's not really the emphasis of these
questions I'd be happy if you just let
this for each other now so far a genius
read it and everything always been on
the same former okay they tell you some
ratio this may give you some kind of
restriction on what the angle can be
actually what the angle is but it's so
he's got a between here and here and
then they say find out some other issues
on the same angle okay but they pushing
over here I have deliberately left
something out what missing is no
restriction right I haven't told you
cedar is over here over here there are
in this question could be anything
now just rewire it come back to this
question over here if I took off that
restriction where feeder is obtuse
restriction like so the question changes
right because I've got a quadrant on
there if can't figure is that I'm not
necessarily in the second quadrant where
else graduate I could be over here right
because all the same remember I said old
this is five in minus twelve
well there's another combination of
these numbers that will give me the same
camera shoots namely let's go over here
it's bigger there it's not five and
minus twelve is it it actually 12 and
minus five do you agree but of course
when you divide them when you take a
ratio
that number yes so in this case all of
the answer I'll use will be the same
it's the same way egg retrieval after
all but you're going to get different
science aren't you instead of this and
yes if I had to go up in second version
the question what what would it be
what would slightly to be you're in the
fourth quadrant have a look you can just
say well in the fourth quadrant only Cod
is positive so therefore sine is
negative or alternatively you could be
thoughtful about the sides of the
triangle you can say wait
if opposite creatures negatives on
hypotenuse we have room in which is
positive right do you say well that'll
be minus 5 over 13 you can use the same
logic you can take on feeder in the
first case it's before projects recorded
supposed to be puppies there or you
could just look carefully at your signs
it was positive on positive 12 over 13
so if they take away that restriction
like I have here they will change the
wording operation ever so slightly
because crew sexy dog might not be just
one thing it could be something else you
don't know which quadrant you're in they
will say find possible values of respect
better because it could be one of two
things
let's quickly have a government it can't
be the equals to 10 billion collection i
turn my quadrants again I like in the
previous question I don't know is
quadrant I'm in there are two
possibilities which one yeah further
answer because if you miss what they're
all positive and this one paid if I
didn't that's the one I'm dealing with
okay now 10 PT equals to two is a
rational number I could rate is ratio
I probably write it as two for one is
that okay
so in one first quadrant see our offices
on adjacent I had better be two over one
so I'll make it about possible just show
my diagrams which reasonable okay
does that look okay take off you can see
why I'm inside coordinates you can see
why position like two of my one day off
obviously I didn't kiss me what I need
okay before we move on to the other
version let's just work a critic Peter
here
Kerr said figure is reciprocal at which
one again to reciprocate silence right
now what it's like I don't know what the
site is I don't know what the hypothesis
keep telling you what is yeah rude
screen there is three I think it's rude
five let me just check it out 1 squared
plus 2 squared is 1 plus 4 which is 5
total it's weird to get to that point so
good it is retribute you're doing things
in your head right
what are the sign therefore is going to
be not opposite on hypotenuse but I want
you to opposite so I'm guessing that
root 2 5 1 - all right okay now you can
want and just like I did up here you can
draw now there's two conversions all on
10th in equal suitable one good we down
er you're going to draw a triangle like
this instead like that do you agree
speed is going to be very grateful to
fit to my original fear that's like the
same sign my two of my one where they
going to go now this is this is where
again if you're careful with your
quadrants you can see what's going on
like you see how the x1 is to the left
that means it's negative right but the y
coordinate is down that means it is also
negative but of course when you take the
ratio those two things cancel up to that
exact but I like to put it on here so I
know actually why why is it also why but
also quantity over here because these
two exactly cancel this is still going
to be root 5 so when you think about 1
over sine theta in this triangle what
helps didn't magnitude of whatever size
the magnet raita value nothing changes
because it's the same triangle is a
culprit I'll just move it around right
so therefore our version to cook their
data
it still has taught me some opposite but
look look see we broke negative two
because we start going down so that's
why you can say thank you to
troubleshoot I'll try to do a if you
won't be really cute you can just say
well it's not the positive ones going to
go okay I transferred and draw the
triangle because the show don't know
what's going on and that's why it's also
the ninja fish one last quick point
before we leave this question which you
don't need to notice all of it but this
is what we write 10 underneath and
folded over here this is if you're going
to choose a baking where your seat over
here you've got 180 degrees minus
speed-up over tea on what you have done
you it's 180 must be done
do you know why you know why 10 is
positive
exactly here and here remember what's
the change I look back the camera right
is that we want more Jasmine right the
tan graph looks like this if you think
about it for doctor 360 you've got the
Midway their asymptote here an asymptote
here and then unlike sine and cosine
which have a period of 360 right can is
a period all 180 you take that thing I
think that's the whole thing and then
you just may be able to help the other
right every 180 degrees every 180
degrees you get a new solution okay
which is why it's over there and then
over there and then we'll come back over
here again if you add 180 degrees more
and more time